you are a foster mom yeah and actually
uh your son is here yes yes I don't know
where can we say hi to Lonnie sure
Lonnie where are
you hi
Lonnie and Milani you're next to Lonnie
and you were a student of Brian's yes
maam
I mean can you give me like one detail
about Briana that I wouldn't know well
she's the best though um she makes us
feel heard not just as students in a
classroom setting but also as human
beings in the world who have a story to
tell and when you think of alternative
school a lot of people think of you know
children who can't be redeemed from the
things that they done but she makes us
believe that we are better than the
worst mistakes we've ever made if
[Applause]
if thank you and if we couldn't get
forgiven for our mistakes I wouldn't be
here so never discount anyone please who
is just trying to find their way it's so
hard to find our way in this world yes
and you started a nonprofit um
Sisterhood of Hope yes if you haven't
cried yet you will with this story so uh
my student demaya the most loving and
loved kid that I've truly ever known uh
actually one of Milani's childhood
friends and actually one of her
classmates at the alternative school um
she was the one that I mentioned she had
two boys before she graduated high
school uh demaya deir and deari very
cute um and so I watched her right um
become a mom and I often reflect on all
the other things that demaya was outside
of being a mom like um call her a
scholar activist because all the Poetry
she ever wrote was about changing the
world and I truly know um that she would
have done so if she had more time and I
loved her so much and I'll never regret
telling her how much that I loved her in
fact I uh I wish that I would have told
her more because I'll never be able to
tell her again um in December of 2022
demaya died in a tragic car accident um
where uh her two sons and her were
ejected from the car and everyone
survived but her and so we founded
Sisterhood of Hope a 501c3 nonprofit
organization with the mission to empower
young girls of color in East St Lewis in
Chicago through the mission of
Sisterhood which can heal Hearts break
barriers and change lives well there are
a few people who wanted to share
something with you take a look at
this hi Briana I'm so proud of you but
really proud is not a good enough word
for what I am you were born to teach and
youve made such a great impact in such a
few short years as a teacher and I
really can't wait to see what you do
next hey Bri if you would have told me
10 years ago that you were going to be
recognized as the teacher of the year I
would have absolutely believed you your
students and the community that you
serve are better because of you and so
am I hi Brianna I'm so proud of the
beautiful strong person you have become
you do an amazing job of advocating for
your students and deserve every award
and Accolade that's coming your way hope
to see you soon love you and
we
as we as a show also want to support all
the work that you're doing and that's
why we have teamed up with our friends
at Five Below and they're donating
$110,000 to your nonprofit
sister that's not all Five Below has got
it all at prices we all love this
holiday season and they're giving you a
$1,000 gift card that can be used at
Five Below stores specifically to stock
up on your classroom dignity closet I
love that thank you so much thank you
Briana for everything and Milani and
Lonnie thank you so much thank you John
thank you so much congratulations on
teacher of the year for all of Illinois
thank you we'll be right back oh my
[Music]
God